وزعمت وزارة الدفاع في موسكو أن
القوات الروسية دمرت
معقلًا لأوكرانيا عن طريق تفجير
دبابة يتم التحكم فيها عن بعد كانت محملة بالمتفجرات
ونشرت وسائل إعلام موالية لروسيا هذا
الفيديو على الإنترنت ، ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كانت الدبابة
قد فُجِّرت عن بُعد أو ما إذا كان
الأوكرانيون قد دمروها جيدًا في هذه الأثناء.
تربح ساحة المعركة مع
احتدام القتال على
خط المواجهة الشرقي والجنوبي ، انضم بن ويدمان من قناة سي إن إن
إلينا الآن من زابوريزيا وقد
عرضنا للتو مقطع فيديو لما تم
الإبلاغ عنه على أنه تكتيك جديد من قبل الروس ،
ما الذي نعرفه في هذه المرحلة.
سنقوم بتشغيل هذا الفيديو مرة أخرى ، وكما
تتحدث
جيدًا ، فإن ما نعرفه وفقًا
لحساب برقية وزارة الدفاع الروسية هو أن هذه
دبابة T-54 والتي يعود تاريخها إلى
السنوات التي أعقبت الحرب العالمية الثانية مباشرةً والتي كانت
معبأة ربما بأكثر من خمسة أطنان
من المتفجرات شديدة الانفجار الآن وفقًا لتلك
الرواية ، يبدو أن سائقًا
ما في تلك الدبابة وجهها بشكل أساسي
في اتجاه الخطوط الأوكرانية
التي تحركت للأمام وعلى بعد حوالي 300 متر
من الخطوط الأوكرانية يبدو أنها
أصيبت.  إنه لغم ثم أصيب
بقذيفة آر بي جي أطلقت من الخطوط الأوكرانية
ثم انفجر الآن لا نعرف
ما إذا كان
الروس قد تمكنوا من التقدم للأمام
أم لا مسافة 300 متر
على الرغم من  حجم هذا
الانفجار ربما
قُتل أو أصيب بعض القوات الأوكرانية ، لكننا لا
نعرف في هذه المرحلة ، لكن من المؤكد أنه
يبدو تكتيكًا جديدًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
يستخدمه الروس لأن هذا
الهجوم المضاد يكتسب وتيرة